salut et bienvenue s'est confiné d'ici
et d'ailleurs aujourd'hui nous partons
en afrique ont paré retrouver régissant
film à martiniquais de trinité qui
vivent et y travaillent depuis quelques
années il nous parlera de cette
destination des raisons qui l'ont amené
et des spécificités du nigeria par
rapport à la martinique s'est tout de
suite quand confiné d'ici et d'ailleurs
[Musique]
salut régis voir on est loin aujourd'hui
on est au nigérienne destination qu'on
n'a pas visité encore non confiné d'ici
et d'ailleurs comment tu t'es retrouvé
aussi loin de la martinique ça
représente combien de kilomètres à peu
près au combien d'heures de vol
alors faut d'abord passer par paris
environ 8 heures puis 6h30 paris la
gauche comme en martinique est un
trinitéen au plus je crois se retrouve
jusque là parce que ça représente quand
même beaucoup de kilomètres le nigeria
par rapport à la martinique
moi c'est de marquer au hasard c'était
surtout aux positions professionnelles
au nigeria à la dose de spécifiquement
et voilà c'est un c'est à la suite des
mezzés dessus des premières expériences
sur wii alors tu travailles dans quoi au
nigeria réduit dans le secteur du
pétrole auxquels un analyste financier
et je m'occupe de vérifier la
rentabilité de transport de matériel
pétrolière alors on parle un petit bout
du bout du nigeria pour commencer mais
nous rêver c'est un beau pays
et oui c'est un très beau pays il
servait surtout qui aimait connus ou
inconnus pour des raisons un peu
mauvaise la guerre et tout ça exactement
à la famille dans le nord du pays voire
à des gens connaissent en france mais ne
dit rien c'est beaucoup d'autres choses
c'est une économie très se développent
et aussi population est une richesse
culturelle qui est méconnu en héros
alors c'est vrai qu'il y avait déjà
quelques petits problèmes liés comme tu
le disais tout à l'heure au terrorisme
et à tous ces groupuscules qui évoluent
là bas donc qui pose déjà des problèmes
de sécurité aujourd'hui se rajoute le
kovy 19 comment est-ce que c'est géré au
nigeria est ce qu'il ya beaucoup de cas
tu nous parlais de confinement tout à
l'heure comment ça se passe exactement
alors de mémoire il y avait plus de 2015
au nigeria a recensé mais il faut savoir
que les campagnes de tests se font au
compte-gouttes les statistiques on ne
connaît pas vraiment
aujourd'hui donc on se fie aux chiffres
donnés par le gouvernement
mais heureusement les chiffres le cul
fut plus fiers notre guillemets ça ce
cas le nombre de morts aujourd'hui a que
58 de tesco millions d'habitants pour le
moment à 19 en tout cas officiellement
d'après les chiffres officiels
c'est pas dramatique en tout cas pour le
moment comment tu as sur toi de ton côté
tu as ta protection pour le coc vide
mais aussi pour tout ce qui pourrait
être beaucoup à ramer compagnie est ce
que tu es en sécurité là où tu es en
tant qu' en tant qu un expat c'est
surtout les entreprises qui assurent la
sécurité des salariés donc d'un point de
vue sanitaire d'un point de vue purement
sécurité de la personne ce sont les
entreprises qui bien sûr tout ça avec
souvent des entreprises privées de
sécurité
et sinon d'un point de vue sanitaire
c'est port du masque obligatoire et
honteux uniquement sortir d'une fois par
semaine entre 9h et 15h est ce que tu as
pu malgré malgré toutes ces conditions
de sécurité un peu particulière visiter
le nigeria j'imagine que le payer très
grands comme tu nous le disait tout à
l'heure très bon également
est ce que tu peux sortir en voir
découvrir c'est assez particulier
derrière d'envoi pour les expats les
entreprises essayent de ne garder un peu
dans des espèces de prison dorée donc on
a l'obligation de rester à les gosses
sauf pour voyage professionnel ou
personnellement j'avais souvent à port
harcourt dans le sud est du pays qui est
la région
les troyennes par excellence mais
l'habitude n'y a rien été complètement
interdites comme on l'a dit précédemment
trouvé raisons de sécurité les
terroristes les kidnappings et c est ce
que les choses au nigeria qui se
rapproche un petit peu de la martinique
qui ressemble un peu à ce que tu as
connu toi oui c'est une vie et est
notamment axé sur cuivre
les jeux seront mangés ignoble elle et
christo s'il laisse oui les banques
voilà d'ailleurs en ce moment ce sont
des mango la content d'être au nigeria
il a donc s'il semble donc surtout
niveau puis la culture en tout cas un
très beau pays avec des spécificités
bien évidemment comme tous les pays
d'ailleurs et il faut faire avec
bah écoute on espère que la situation va
s'arranger d'un point de vue économique
déjà pour le nigeria par rapport aux
combis 19 et puis aussi pour la
stabilité bien évidemment sécuritaire du
pays avec boko haram et tout ça parce
que ça c'est un très beau pays qu'on
visitera merci d'ailleurs nous faire
parvenir un petit peu quelques images de
ce beau pays pour le découvrir un petit
peu en espérant pouvoir le voir mieux et
dans d'autres conditions en tout quatre
ans soin de toi sois prudent on espère
le revoir très bientôt en martinique
c'est prévu et oui ben c'était lui bon
bah écoute on espère en tout cas soit
prudent d'ici là merci beaucoup de cette
petite visite chez toi à lagos au
nigeria merci beaucoup régis et à très
bientôt on l'espère voilà le nigeria une
destination qu'on va rajouter à notre
carnet de voyage dans confiné d'ici et
d'ailleurs c'est maintenant terminé et
on se retrouve très vite sur la première
à très bientôt
[Musique]